[Musique]
sur les réseaux sociaux dans les
sections réservées aux commentaires ou
encore dans les forums de discussions au
seul but parfois des internautes disons
irrespectueux et provocateur ils
cherchent d'abord et avant tout attirer
l'attention ou à pousser les autres à
bout certains le font par le moyen d'
insulte et d' attaques personnelles et
ce de façon répétée soutenu ce type de
personnes là sont souvent appelés troll
mais d'où vient ce terme ce mot au juste
il remonte en fait à la fin des années
80 et au début des années 90 sur les
tous premiers forums de discussion les
salles de clavardage des utilisateurs
l'essai des messages irrévérencieux ou
carrément hors sujet pour faire dévier
le cours d'une conversation mais il faut
attendre quelques années avant que le
terme se répandent c'est en 1992 que
troll est d'abord recenser dans les
dictionnaires avec une définition qui
concerne directement les comportements
en ligne et avec le recul on constate
qu'ils semblaient avoir deux originaux
mot trolls qui se rejoignent dans le
concept disons contemporain premièrement
un troll bien sûr c'est un personnage
folklorique issus des contes et légendes
scandinaves peut-être hideuse et plus
amicale l'autre signification moins
connue celle là vient de l'ancien
français un terme trop les un terme de
chasse qui veut dire partir en quête de
gibier ce terme est passé à l'anglais à
travers le verbe tout chaud ou trolling
ce qu'on retrouve aussi au canada
francophone trollé pêche à la traîne on
laisse entraîner un appât derrière une
embarcation pour faire mordre les
poissons et ce verbe flooding était
aussi utilisé par des pilotes américains
pendant la guerre du vietnam en voulant
dire chercher à provoquer une réaction
chez l'ennemi pour révéler sa présence
bien sûr ces dernières années la notion
de troll a pris une nouvelle ampleur
avec l'avènement des réseaux sociaux on
avait émergé des usines ou des fermes
acte roll la campagne présidentielle
2016 aux états unis en est un très bon
exemple les usines à troll russe avait
alors cherché à déstabiliser la
démocratie américaine l'objectif général
n'est donc plus de seulement polluer les
échanges mais aussi de manipuler
carrément l'opinion publique de chemins
et l'asie ni à grande échelle on
conseille souvent d'ignorer les trolls
dont fidh d'autres choses ne nourrissez
pas les trolls comme dit un dicton très
populaire sur le web ne lui répondait
pas car ils ne demandent que ça aussi on
peut signaler un comportement
problématique à une autorité compétente
le responsable d'un site par exemple
autre possibilité bloquer un troll ou
désactiver les commentaires d'une
publication sachez aussi que des trolls
ont déjà été condamnés pour avoir
enfreint la loi pour diffamation en
ligne ou encore intimidation harcèlement
ou menaces bref vaut mieux se méfier des
trolls s'en tenir loin tout en
n'hésitant pas à signaler leurs actions
qui polluent le web
[Musique]